time to to begin topic for today is
globalization women and faith or gender
and faith and we have with us a guest
today muna abu sulaiman executive
director of the prince alwaleed bin
talal foundation and the leading media
personality in the Middle East and she
has served as a co-host of Middle East
broadcasting company company's most
popular social program and he's she's
also been named as a young global leader
by the world economic forum forum for
2,000 and in 2004 and serves as a
lecturer at king saud university in
Riyadh in American literature so we want
to welcome muna with us I'll first offer
a few comments and then we'll have muna
address the class and the procedure is
the same as you know so so let me just
start by noting these two approaches
that that I have identified as we were
talking about market and the corporation
that is something kind of moral
assessment of market from outside in
terms of its goals and so forth and
nature and kind of internal functioning
of it I think the same thing can be done
for globalization as a whole and as I
survey the readings and discussions that
we and case study that we had for this
for this session it strikes me that some
of our readings were really readings
about assessing globalization as a whole
and the others were maybe minority of
them asking question about functioning
is particular women's functioning within
globalization processes themselves now
many especially feminist scholars and
you've read some of those are very much
concerned with this a global assessment
of globalization processes and not their
note not only
kind of absence of women in many of the
top leadership positions they know not
only kind of a men's way of relating
allegedly within the globalization
processes themselves but also kind of
the whole thrust of globalization
process is kind of a masculine thrust of
globalization processes frankly I myself
made because I'm a male I don't quite
know what to do with this a side of
things and I wasn't wasn't too keen on
some of the readings that we had for
today left knee rather rather puzzled
and to say the least right I know that
you had interesting discussions and
debates I don't know how fruitful they
were for you but I know that the
strategy was I think we revised by our
TAS to have divided you into teams and
then debate the merits and demerits of
the case whether what weather weather
what rape is two women that is
globalization to the world as we as we
experience it so I won't comment on any
of these because I don't want know much
about about it i'm not sure exactly i
know how to properly assess it what i
want to to make some comments on is on
kind of these internal processes within
globalization in the place of women
within globalization processes and i
want to distinguish as we have done i
see i think all along just a reminder
between economic globalization and
cultural globalization i think it's good
for us to keep these two types of
globalization or aspects i think
probably is better to save globalization
distinct in our minds although
concretely they're always deeply
intertwined because of obviously
economic aspect of globalization has
cultural underpinnings and cultural
consequences and cultural one also rides
on economic processes but it's good to
maybe
friendship between the two so and I want
to then comment about role of women in
the context and faith in context of
globalization processes it would regard
to economic globalization as well as
with regard to cultural globalization
and I think in terms of economic
globalization we can maybe again
distinguish kind of in terms of the role
of women within globalization processes
in terms of women as global leaders and
i will make virtually no comments on
that that's why Munna is here she is a
young global a global leader and she may
want to comment on on that aspect but
instead I want to look at women as local
poor right so you can say it's a as a
global leaders all as a local poor in
that sense in it what I'm going to say
now is an extension of the comments that
we or discussions that we have during
our last session and here I want to
build on a one side comment that I made
about the role of Pentecostalism with
regard to women especially the women in
developing world Pentecostalism is one
of the fastest growing Christian it's
only one denomination kind of movements
I think it's probably the best to
describe it it started in 1906 and by
now his son likes something like a half
a billion members world worldwide and I
want to just remind you or elaborate a
bit more about the impact or at least
the thesis about the impact of that
movement on women in the developing
developing countries background for that
is a kind of experience of many women in
developing countries of living in almost
like a pre-modern very hierarchical and
very patriarchal structures and
especially in Latin America with the
idea of kind of a wayward male who roams
at large does he's his own thing and
happens not particularly to care
for what's happening in the family and
it's a kind of picture that many of you
probably are not familiar from from
personal experience I'm not familiar
from from personal experience but that's
who my grandfather was one of those
wayward kind of males who will used to
work out in outside of the of the house
my grandmother was there with kids in
the ended up being about eight of them
this woman led a miserable life because
this guy would as the male's used to do
when they got their salary he would go
and drink the salary with his with his
body buddies and all the work that has
been done has been spent on booze and on
women and this poor woman with the kids
was just left completely completely on
her own that's a kind of almost like a
pre-modern and I'm set up right but then
I added to this is a kind of
globalization processes that dislocate
women from the land often is a source of
a source of at least feeding their their
families and kind of insert them into
into this this whirlwind of of change
and the question then becomes how the
women developing countries cope with
that and one of the one of the ways
coping mechanism has been pentecostalism
at least that's the argument of Bernice
Martin a Bernice Martin who has written
an article called Pentecostal gender
paradox and often women then embrace
Pentecostalism as as religion partly
because when the coast ilysm gives them
a sense of agency Pentecostalism the
kind of a very much religion of active
participation of Leyte and what's prize
very highly is what are called spiritual
gifts and those spiritual gifts can be
gifts of prophecy gifts of healing all
sorts of gifts that any member of this
congregation can practice and often
women excel in gifts of prophecy and
gifts of healings so within that
structure they get to get a sense of
authority even though it's true that
they don't have any formal Authority in
terms of formal Authority structure
hierarchies retained the
male is on the top of the of the of the
leadership hierarchy women are the flock
but nonetheless they require significant
amount of power in order to within that
community and exercise leadership
leadership skills which are then brings
its ability to speak to groups which are
then transferred to a secular kinds of
realms so there's an empowerment of
women that goes on and connected with
that also there goes on domestication of
the mail because part and parcel of the
code of this religious community well
you are not roam around right you've got
to stay put you got to take care of the
family you ought not drink and so forth
and then you've got a consolidation of
the home as a basic economic unit and
the ability of women I think to lead a
better lives and to control their
environments is much better of a way now
you can see why it's a paradox of gender
right this hierarchical structures are
retained egalitarianism has not been
introduced yet at all it but nonetheless
it's something that women at least that
the thesis have embraced and that has
improved the ways in which they would
have otherwise lived both in the context
of traditional patriarchal hierarchical
society as well as in the context of
kind of changes in transformation that's
happening in globalization during the
course of globalization processes with
that classical traditional family
structure so that's one of the possible
effects of of popular religion on women
in the context of globalization
processes now that being said that maybe
from some angle too rosy of a picture
and I don't think that Bernice Martin or
anybody else or to underestimate the
extent to which also various religious
traditions have participated in kind of
legitimizing and stabilizing the order
that exploits the factor
women and that keeps them in subjugated
subjugated position my sense that in
this regard as in regard of many of the
things that we have discussed in this
course various religions Christianity
certainly which I know the best included
had had this ambivalent relationship
they're both liberating and in some
senses they can be also enslaving and
again it depends partly on the kind of
register in which each of these faiths
is being played so that's the one side
of the thing that I wanted to comment
comment on and the other side concerning
cultural globalization I think we have
we have read for this for this session
the debate in Turkey but also in other
places about head scarves and the role
of head scarves in of the place of women
how it be how it is being understood
with regard to the wearing a debate of
wearing off of head scarves the whole
issue of veiling has become really a
flashpoint right of so many debates at
so many different levels and it's simply
interesting to register this as social
and cultural phenomenon it has political
implications major cultural implication
civilizational clashes implication
everything is being kind of fought
around many other things but very
notable around the question of women's
veiling particular kind of failing
whether or not and how that might that
might that might work turkey is a very
interesting case right in youth I don't
need to repeat that very much France is
a similarly interesting case which from
the perspective of United States for the
most part people think what's gotten
into this guy meaning Sarkozy right that
he would want to regulate what can and
what cannot be cannot be worn but in
European context it's a very
alive debate i remember when i was i was
in croatia with a friend from from
germany just when there was not just
this sacrifice comment about burqa that
can or cannot be worn but also about the
swimming outfit appropriate to miss
muslim women now these are outlawed also
you can't wear those in public swimming
pools and so we are we were discussing
this this thing in the creation
creations that there are a lot of kind
of public nude beaches right there's no
problem with with that right and so i
don't quite get it right that you will
in french don't don't necessarily make
any losses with regard to that right and
i don't quite get it that you would
allow one but not the the other though
my friend found himself defending French
and the Sarkozy because he thought it
was as I think many many people do that
the veiling is a symbol simply of
subjugation of women by the way
controversy around Danish cartoons
partly was triggered by commons of one
of the imams in one of the danish
mosques about women keeping them at home
and making sure that they're veiled and
the journalists of the magazine which of
the newspaper which have published the
cartoons have Candice finely taped that
that that sermon friday sermon and then
translated it and then published it and
there was a huge uproar in Danish
society now this is going against the
basic Danish values and it triggered are
quite undergo mystic relationship
between Muslim community and Danish
government as well as at least some of
the danger then intellectuals this all
simply to say that for whatever reason
and maybe that's what we can discuss
partly partly in this class and maybe
that's what you've discussed also in
to the turkey case this has been for
whatever reason a very important issue
which in which the kind of relationship
between Islam and the contemporary
Western culture are being negotiated I
say contemporary because it isn't it's
been that long that even in the West
there was a forms of bailing that has
been this has been used my my own nanny
okay it was it was kind of on the
fringes of the West right in Croatia but
she used to always wear I think she was
like your typical of Russian babushka
right hulu who used to used to wear this
this scarf and nobody thought there was
any any problem and since I'm so
autobiographical today in my own dad's
church I remember as a kid I
transitioned from the position where
women had to come to church covered to
the position where it was allowed for
them not to [ __ ] covered girls could
always come and once you get married you
had to have a covering right and there
was a big internal debates until you
negotiated yourself from one position to
the other because it says in first
Corinthians 11 that women should cover
themselves when they pray and therefore
in church they should wear a veil so I'm
mentioning this simply to indicate this
is a contemporary very contemporary
Western debate which has kind of
forgotten the development of the Western
culture away from any kind of a link to
to the sense that veil represents can
form of overall form of oppression now
what's fascinating and this is where I'm
going to end with and maybe maybe a
proposal I'm reporting here on on the
piece that a newly third goal a has
published on Turkey's debate about
veiling one of the interesting aspects
of this has been she she notes that
unlike the
traditional practice of wearing hijab in
the modern Turkey the wearing of veil
was perceived to be and was exercised as
an explicit choice it wasn't something
that one simply inherited as the part
and parcel of the tradition it was
explicit choice and as a choice also it
had been the sense of certain political
agency right and then you're in a
situation where you're exercising
political agency in order to defend
which is a very much of a modern right
phenomenon in the context of the modern
relatively modern state in order to
defend a traditional way of doing doing
things which is in a sense again you see
the paradox in which we were involved
because just about all religious
decisions and stances in the modern
world are a matter of choice Peter
Berger has talked his written in one
book a sociologist of religion entitled
heretical imperative under the
conditions of modernity everybody's a
heretic meaning in the sense that
everybody has to make explicit choice
what it is that they are going to
embrace and what it is that they're not
going to to embrace and so you see both
in the case of Pentecostal women and I
think in the case of the debates around
the hijab where that there's a in a
sense under conditions of modernity a
sense of agency but it's connected also
to information of something deeply
traditional maybe and also deeply deeply
religious that's by the way true also of
various forms of certainly Christian
fundamentalisms right a lot of people
have noted that fundamentalists are the
best users of contemporary media right
they use media in a very savvy way this
is a very modern global medium but it is
being used in order to to promote what
seems to be at least non modern if it's
not anti modern kind of engendering here
you see also how
religion is involved in the
transformation processes and how it
seeks to impact also how it attempts to
to impact also the larger cultural
environment in which we find ourselves
and in many of these cases women are at
the center of the debate